with bitter debates that break out into
actual fighting Ukraine's Parliament is
a microcosm of the country as a peasant
no boozing selfish ladies and gentlemen
Ukraine now finds itself in the middle
of a war our enemy is banditry and
revanche ISM armed units are now
guarding the regional Parliament in
kharkov ukraine second largest city in
the night pro-russian demonstrators
stormed the building and set fire to it
interior ministry troops finally
regained control in the early hours
Ukraine's interim president is
describing latest operations against
pro-russian separatists as a success
shudder where shooter during the night
government forces were able to regain
control of the security services
building in Donetsk and this morning we
were able to clear all the separatists
from the Kharkov regional administration
building for chess purchase fire guns
and threw hand grenades at police
several officers were badly injured
security forces will now cordon off the
center of Kharkov as well as Luhansk and
Donetsk where pro-russian separatists
have ceased buildings and erected
barricades Western countries are
watching the events in Ukraine with
growing concern fearing that the Kremlin
is trying to destabilize its neighbour
but Russia is only making bland
statements items to DF leadership hasn't
made any gestures towards the south
eastern regions even though the people
there believe that their interests are
being ignored near puzzled it if you
could see another voltage got home but
the new below follow much lavrov's
comments came in response to unusually
strong words from Washington if Russia
moves into eastern Ukraine either
overtly or covertly this would be a very
serious escalation we call on President
Putin and his government to cease all
efforts to destabilize Ukraine and we
caution against further military
intervention in Donetsk and other
Ukrainian cities people can only wait
and hope for an end to the conf